[Music]
what is going on this morning what is
going on this morning are you talking to
you
uh we're gonna make waffles i know i can
see the ingredients looks so fun yeah
he's been wanting waffles all week but
our week is get up and go yeah he likes
uh
waffles made at home not the ones that
we order
yes the ones that we make
oh i see yeah
he knew all the ingredients wow you're
like a pro already where's the mixing
bowl
yo pro dude
how did you wash this last time
i just used a wet paper towel
is that the right way yeah i think so i
don't know how else i would wash it
because it has all these like
wires instead yeah i just use a white
paper towel and i wipe it down okay
okay so we're gonna do a cup and a half
of
this powder hopefully we have enough
okay okay
so i think we need look i want that one
that one yeah look look at the box which
one looks the same
one and a half
which was it yep that one
yes
good job
we put powder all the way up to that
line oh my goodness okay you go
we do it again
is it is it there is it at one and a
half yeah or not yet
perfect
now we need water
no spill no spill we need water
here come here come here we gotta
measure it we need two thirds is there
on there is no no come here how much
water do you do you know we need to oh
up to that line okay let's go look look
you know why yeah right here it's the
same measurement here
yes okay cool
is it on that line no no it's not it's
too much water
let me see
it's way too much water where was the
water supposed to go to
what line
[Music]
yeah is it above or below
yeah it is above okay let's dump a
little bit okay
let's see
[Music]
okay check this one i think i think too
much how is it now
wait no no it's not measure it yeah
double check dude it's right here is it
below or above
below yeah then we need a little bit
more water oh man it has to be perfect
okay let's see wait wait wait don't move
it it has to be still
i don't know let's go a little low
okay let's see what's going on with that
face
that's good enough go for it
okay the water is gonna come out of here
okay okay that's the slow slow slow all
right
dude oh my
i'll dump it okay you dump it a lot
there you go oh it's blessed i love it
all of it
okay three tablespoons
what do you have in there egg water and
powder and powder yeah let me see well
no
okay we're gonna do six of these
here you hold it you dump it okay i'll
tell you six of them
whoa dump it
one
two two
three
four
five
six perfect
good job dude
now what do you think we do
i don't know we did everything yeah we
mixed it in
it
it cracked its head off cracked his head
off
[Music]
you're a baby
you really look like a monkey this
morning
baby go baby baby
is it burning is it burning nope not
that i think it's not that i can see
it's going to make enough
i don't think i put enough
see what that'll be enough because once
you press it down it does squeeze it to
the side
peanut butter peanut butter on it
peanut butter is yummy no i want
nutella okay
what do you want on it i'll take some
peanut butter but it's delicious
cuny guy look
there it is okay ready
golden brown wow there you go that's
yours you're about to put a ton of dudes
yeah go with papa go to the nutella
station with dad he'll help you
get a spoon too okay
[Music]
do you want one with banana baby uh if
you want bananas to open that in there i
don't care well no just do one for me
then oh okay we don't want one huh no
no i'll put one in there
tell him tell him
is it yummy
you have a french mustache
do you know what that means
you kidding me guy no but it sounds
funny
it looks delicious would you believe me
monkey if i told you that your papa is a
funny guy yeah you think he's funny
all the time or a little bit
a little bit a little bit yeah what
about mom's mom bunny mm-hmm a little
bit or a lot
[Music]
the public doesn't know that
all right here's a adult one
we got banana in here
well because he wants the kid one with
zero nutrients
this one is it's squishy
because it has a soft banana in it but
you gotta put the nutella on there huh
oh yeah oh
yes oh
[Music]
and then
got my
drink in the morning
look at my waffle taco
um
yeah look at my son's face
[Music]
all right so we're getting ready to go
to grandma's house this week
and ma bear already gave me a hint
of the toys that taika tyka's packing
and it sounds so funny yeah so he has a
little um
little rug yeah
all the tools you want to bring leave
them on the rug so you go see what's on
the rug okay can you take this dirty
towel up for the laundry yeah and
actually all those clothes except for
that
all right so i'm excited because we're
going to be there for like a week so
my girl is like make sure you bring
enough toys so you won't get bored
these are toys
so there's a random
like bell pepper
a spider
a banana a fishing line
a campfire and a cape
how come you wanted those ones monkey i
don't know what's this isn't it funny
whoa it's really funny like you can't
have just one game going and there's a
car
and a gun
i've never played with that dinosaur
which dinosaur
oh the green one
oh my god you're so funny
okay go
whoa
oh my goodness
hey we're not trying to make a big mess
before we leave
look at all these things you got to put
this away now
no yeah you do no
no no
toys at grandma's house
okay so i want tyka to be
very self-sufficient and independent so
i want i always try to have him pack
that's why he has his toys
so monkey excuse me we're gonna be
excuse me my grandma's one so that's
monday
tuesday excuse me
wednesday night there's not right yes it
doesn't matter
okay monday tuesday wednesday thursday
friday
monday tuesday wednesday thursday friday
and come back on saturday okay so
what do you need to put on what clothes
do you wear
shirt that was a shirt
nope
you wear underwear
so that's how many underwear do you need
one two three four five six okay good
job get your underwear
that's really good hurry up
okay cool he learned crowd bought from
jiu jitsu
so let's get let's get those underwear
so put it put it on the dome don't
unfold it make sure it stays nice and
folded
one two no every day you get an
underwear that's skinny
[Music]
i like how he's getting one at a time
time you gotta do it wholesale dude you
gotta get all six out once we're doing a
retail slow what other clothes do you
put on
i'm sure sure okay how many shirts do
you need
six are you sure about that and i'm
julie
okay
so now you do it one
two
and this is how you run a business folks
four
it's pretty good though it is pretty
good
five
six okay what else do you wear
i think that's all you need yeah maybe
the last one
yep i think that's all you need
uh what about if it gets cold
do you want to bring maybe like a pound
or two
okay so we got that what else do you put
on
how many pajamas are you gonna get six
no
you need one
okay bring two yeah you just need two
monkeys there's two
six is too many you're gonna wear a
pajama every day
no you wear the same one
and then you have a backup one yeah you
just bring two
he's like i'm gonna bring i'm gonna
bring six toothbrushes
yes only two
and this is what happens when you run a
business yeah he starts taking it
literally oh good job okay two
okay what else do you put on
socks yeah how many socks are you gonna
wear every day two
uh maybe four maybe six maybe six socks
like her underwear yeah
that was crazy yeah don't be disgusting
like your mom this one
no
don't put it
monkey where's papa he's in jail where's
jail right here show it to me
what
could you tell your story
i've been in jail for like 10 minutes
because you take your money for you for
a lot why did you take my money i didn't
take any money
no you framed me
you framed me you bad cup
he gave me back my money where did that
come from huh what money he gave me
money he did i don't know yeah you can
but you couldn't you could give
me that girl
which girl what girl what girl
oh
okay let's go stay in jail you and other
girls oh you're not a girl
yeah turn off the light too turn off the
light
see you later losers
all right going to target now
and before we go in
we need to have a list
so that we don't end up buying stuff we
don't need what's the game plan mama i
mean there's some private stuff that i'm
gonna buy like what
um what's private
you know but what like private stuff i
don't want to talk about it but i'm just
kidding uh just like a present
um um
what else did i needed
oh
some feminine hygiene products like
mouthwash
feminine feminine mouthwash
for your
mouth vagina
yeah but no matter your mouth china or
your pube or your pube right
now
they close your ears young man
uh-oh every time we see one of these
guys
uh oh and then we got a softy mama who
gets a soft heart oh yeah i love my kids
it's not part of our list
yeah it is a hat
i don't think you have this one before
huh
just take it uh
oh ultimate decisions what are we going
to do mama we're going to do
no way get out of here
no not a hat
so this is the toughest part of
parenting right
where your kid wants something and
obviously you want your kid to have
everything too because you love them so
much and you work so hard and you want
your kid to have everything that you
didn't have right
but then
how do you teach them
the value of hard work how do you teach
them that they can't just however they
have if they didn't work for it
themselves yet and they're so young that
they only know like 30 words how do you
explain all that
that's the tough part
[Music]
i just think it's so funny people are
hurting so it's hilarious because he
wanted to get down there and then me and
mom be like don't get down there you're
gonna get hurt
and uh he's like no i want to try it i'm
like all right then you're gonna learn
things the hard way so he goes in there
of course he's playing with the wheel
and then the thing like squish his
finger a little bit and he's perfectly
fine
but of course it hurt him but now he
learned sometimes you gotta learn the
hard way huh mister
ain't nobody trying to talk to you you
troll
[ __ ] damn
it's always good when you got the when
you know your spouse got your back you
know everything always feels so good
you're trolling
i got hurt and you're laughing at me i'm
trying to be your friend
well he's our son we could laugh at him
are these the private things they're
telling me about yes you son of a [ __ ]
teach me about these guys nothing
what does a man need to know about these
to keep his woman happy
just leave us alone the entire month
the whole month yeah i thought only one
week out of the month fine so the week
before the month the that week yeah we
start feeling bloated cranky like mood
swings
and then the first day it starts then
it's the worst it's the heaviest yeah so
then we go here
and about day two or three then we go
here
three or four we go here that's it so
which one are you gonna get a bunch of
green ones i see
what do you mean it's a variety
oh it's a variety pack
but what if you only only bust the heavy
loads let's just get a box of green ones
it's you never just bust a heavy load
you don't no oh i only bust heavy loads
depends you've been kind of lacking
these days what are you serious i'm just
kidding let's be my age oh i do want to
try these things
what do you got in your hand there you
diva cup
that's it so you put this cup inside of
your body yeah and it holds all the
blood
and after 12 hours you dump it out wash
it and you put it back in there like a
reverse condom almost
yeah crazy but not reverse condoms it
looks like a reverse condom it's a
literal condom it's holding it's the
same concept that holds it what do you
think is more comfortable this or like
something that soaks it all up
i don't know i've never tried this
i want to
try it let me know how it goes okay
take it do you think mama needs it
yeah you don't want the blood to come
out huh
come on
baby
this is all we needed look at this this
is really cool
so now they make kleenex in a
cylindrical shape
so you can put it inside your cup holder
for your car
and what's crazy is i didn't think it
would take that long for people to make
this because people always need kleenex
in their car when you got that big
square shaped one it's usually on the
dashboard or in the rear dash it's
flying around everywhere and finally
they make one
in 2021 unless i'm tripping and they've
been making i don't even know but it's
the first time i've ever seen this and
you can put this in your cup holder like
one of the ones you're not using
all right so we just got to
the food place for lunch
and on yelp it looked really good we're
always in the mood for our italian
sandwich
and this place is called roma deli and i
think it's also a bodega which is super
cool
but we lost the dude
so game plan
go inside
buy some sandwiches me and mother eat in
the car and then we'll feed tyka uh when
he gets up
this place is legit
look at all these yummy meats
cheeses
and then look at all these yummy sauce
oh my goodness
look at that
olives
even the desserts that come again those
guys
look at those guys oh
all these cookies and biscuits
so this is our little lunch setup action
i'm so curious what your food looks like
because it looks so good when they're
making it
that one
did you just have an orgasm
that was so disgusting
look at that beefy green
oh i love how they cut it too
see you later let me see take a bite oh
okay okay
that bread looks so good too
oh i need a bite of that too that looks
so good i think i got the wrong one
oh look at that thing just gushing out
your mouth
[Music]
i do wish the bread was warm but then
that's pretty good
hey what's going on up there
throwing down some fresh laundry i see
yeah i'm lazy
just got home
from being out and about
so we're gonna hang out
relax
and enjoy our day
and the banks say nah
and we will see you guys tomorrow
[Music]
please don't crash